Did you know that the soap you use to wash
your face may actually alter the density of
krill poop?
It’s actually a big deal.
Hi guys, Lissette here for Dnews.
You may already be familiar with how plastic
in the ocean is killing wildlife, but it’s
more than just plastic soda rings strangling
seabirds and fish.
The impact of plastic goes far beyond just
what we can immediately see - especially because
of tiny bits of plastic that end up in the
ocean, called microplastics.
They’re having a ton of secondary effects
and unexpected consequences.
Though there is no standard definition, microplastics
are generally defined as smaller than 5 mm.
In the ocean, these come from larger pieces
of plastic that have degraded over time or
straight from our products - like the small
plastic beads in our body wash and the plastic
fibers in our clothes.
A recent study published in the journal Environmental
Science and Technology, found plastics could
be changing food dispersion!
Researchers found that zooplankton - which
are small marine animals like krill and copepods
- eat microplastics.
Not good.
Because once the tiny sea creatures eat these
plastic bits, they then excrete them in their
fecal pellets - yeah poop.
The thing is, this plastic makes their feces
weigh less so it sinks much more slowly....
And the fact that they’re sinking more slowly
means there’s also more time for other animals
to eat these pellets, marine animals like
turtles, fish and birds..
Without the plastic, the feces would sink
faster, getting to the bottom of the ocean
where it would be consumed by coprophagous
bottom dwellers.
But, now all of a sudden, it is being consumed
by a new group of marine life.
Which is a big problem.
First, because the plastics themselves contain
toxic chemicals.
And second, because plastics absorb toxins
from the surrounding water - this makes their
toxicity many times greater than the surrounding
water itself.
So, when marine animals eat the plastic poop
pellets, it could be deadly.
The microplastics contain chemicals - like
BPA and Phthalates and when consumed can cause
organ damage, genetic mutations, reproductive
issues, developmental abnormalities and disrupt
hormone systems.
In their study, Rochman and colleagues found
that exposure to polyethylene microplastics
for two months led to liver stress and altered
gene expression in japanese medaka fish (Oryzias
latipes).
In another study, which was published in the
journal Environmental Pollution, scientists
found that goby fish, that were exposed to
microplastics, readily confused them for food,
which in turn decreased the amount of real
food they ate.
Again, not good.
And multiple studies on mollusks, have found
that BPA leads to endocrine disruption that
causes mollusks to have additional female
organs, engrossed sex glands, and even higher
mortality.
Basically, microplastics can really make some
marine life sick.
And because we eat these fish, they may end
up making us sick too - as was suggested by
the United Nations Environment Programme through
their call to ban microplastics from cosmetics.
However, research on the impact of microplastics
in humans is currently limited.
But, with more than five trillion bits of
plastic currently in the ocean that reaches
concentrations of up to 100,000 particles
per cubic meter and more being pumped into
our environment, it definitely warrants more
research.
Especially given that one tiny plastic bead
that came from a soap can be cycled through
multiple fish and fish poo back to fish and
on to us to repeat the cycle all over again.
But this is just one of the many stories you
could tell about our oceans.
Why not tell your own in your style with a
website?
No domain extension will help you tell your
story like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
And because you watch DNews, you can get 15%
off Domain Dot Com’s names and web hosting
by using the code DNews when you check out.